6 25 on your monday morning what's
driving you crazy we're getting more
viewer feedback on that 35 mile an hour
speed limit in the airport connector
tunnels
last month reed airport's joe rachel
explained the speed limit there were
nearly 150 traffic incidents in 2018 and
2019 some of which included fatalities
drivers need to exercise more caution he
said and we believe reduced speeds are
necessary to curtail the frequency of
accidents while joe said enforcement of
the speed limit is out of the airport's
hands we're still hearing from
frustrated drivers trying to do the
right thing like lori who says i go the
speed limit i get honked at and nearly
run off the road i don't feel safe going
the speed limit and anonymous g
i'm constantly tailgated cut off
threatened given the middle finger all
for observing the law it's gotten so bad
lately i put my weapon on the passenger
seat why don't they put up flashing
lights to let people know the speed
limit
okay that's a good question we're going
to check into that and let you know
thanks again to joe rachel from the
airport lori and anonymous g buckle up
drive carefully please put down that
phone you can join the driving you crazy
conversation at traffic 8 8newsnow.com